c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et comme anne hidalgo bien sûr bien sûr
as et qui travaille bien sûr pour
bouygues pour buengo lé pa maire de
paris les chefs de chantier au sérieux
car on fait les travaux en même temps
par tous at elle fait un truc doit faire
un petit peu onéreux humaines des rues
frais à la rue elle est comme ça le vaut
de faire des travaux dans la rue à dire
quelque chose s'est cassé est vide je
fais des travaux c'est anne hidalgo qui
arrive à leur envoyais churchill
c'est un truc de ouf 7,9 alors c'est
vous qui n'habite pas paris à l'est pas
alors paris c'est un milieu puis tout
c'est pareil enfin car tu les as ici
tenir tu sors à paris à des rats qui
tâta le monde qui te prend ici tu peux
pas faire 100 m en voiture je trouve
qu'on a dépassé de 7 km heure de moyenne
à 4 quasiment divisé par deux quoi
pourquoi
mais passé de 7 km heure de moyenne à 4
non paris chargé les trottoirs élargis
les trottoirs plus les camions au moins
deux places dès qu'il ya un bus puis
personnes place ça fait un bouchon on
est bien obligé de livrer on va pas dire
ah bah à l'allergie trottoir on y voit
plus à la boutique on est marqué à
droite autour des missions du coup ça ne
voulait pas on n'est pas à droite ont
fait pas de politique si injuste on veut
circuler non c'est pas ta son n'y a
personne qui se présente de vous dire ça
va être compliqué des gens comme m je
suis à deux doigts de je te dis je suis
à deux doigts de présenter benhaim sa
boulette aura il va partir à toutes les
envoyer sur un gendarme de saint tropez
thouet samba bien sûr c'est que si tôt
c'est un crack toujours et toujours
c'est ma spécialité
et alors vous connaissez la tradition ce
avec le mardi on commence toujours par
un zoom baba et jean michel berrit
l'attenté vous faire une vanessa vous a
pas trop plu se voit pas du tout on va
même découvrir votre tête de série
[Musique]
et
ok mais bien mal de repos il est temps
de changer ils sont livrés et non vous y
allez vrai là dedans tu étais je reçois
envoyer quelqu'un il a acheté un mac do
ils vous avaient acheté un mac do ça
vous a plu
un siège à des attouchements aux
poissons a la chance d'avoir les
chroniqueurs les plus talentueux du paf
notamment dans les anciens journalistes
comme justement valérie on à eric on a
on à jean-michel eysseric jean-michel
aux visiteurs ses formes blanches ou
charlemagne exclu acharnement non c'est
bon jean-michel za presse écrite alors
on comprend parce qu'avec sa diction
tuer le mot 20 heures de tf1 et toutes
ces bafouille un jt et dure deux jours à
la série kaulitz après le jour même et
ça en fait quand huit lentilles parles
tu comprends mais à peu près alors en
hommage à kad olivier voici le nouveau
jean-michel à peu près 100 michel à peu
près quand il parle on comprend tout
mais à peu près c'est un mec un brave
paysan cachette à jour voilà pourra
venir ils achètent eu une tronçonneuse à
la danse à comice agricole lâchait telle
méfier avec cette rosso deux là vous
avez coupé au moins 10 par jose
jean-michel à peu près pour lui raconter
une blague c'est un enfer il le seuil le
jour il parviendra
il revient sa fable wii ou à sa femme le
soir est liée à leur temps la coupe est
gros mieux achats et couper un champ
nous je suis excusé du spa possible pour
entasser gpal y retourne demain c'est
pas beau syrte au lendemain il revient
il en a coupé 2 elle n'en peut plus je
vous la fait courte humble jean-michel à
peu près quand ils voient que ça prend
pas il l'a fait court comme avec ses 9
le week-end seront ils retournent voir
le vendeur il écoutait ce pas possible
j'ai été de trois jours de suite j'ai pu
en couper deux ennemis maximum d'arbres
il dispose aussi pour tancer ils
marchent mer mais heureusement cet
appareil dur dur jean-michel à peu près
tellement doué qui peut se transformer
en jean michel pas de chute dans le
monde elle prend la tronçonneuse
belgique ce bruit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là quelque chose de drôle après
coup c'est l'immersion
on est conscient comme idée je la vois
là c'est pour ça qu'on faisait
bienveillant un vrai métier m'a bien sûr
et confort je m'en suis rendu compte
aussi jeudi de la vienne voilà merci
maliki alors que c'est déjà compliqué
pour vos chroniqueurs de faire des
interventions qui sont intéressantes
mais en plus vous faites tout pour les
déstabiliser dans celui-ci vous faites
si pendant qu'il parle et vous pensez ne
pas de filmer vouloir fait des grimaces
en fait c'est comme si un prof interrogé
ses élèves et qui faisait composant la
réponse exactement la même photo est
passé par s il est justement c'est
paraissent manar comme farès justement
sainte reine on va le voir dans la dent
même année je vais rentrer dans les deux
magots c'est n'en sortira pas vivant
mohamed larbi fils est malade alors pour
réussir à vraiment le déstabiliser
justement vous avez décidé de vous
inspirer du plus grand spécialiste de
grimaces de tous les temps sans rapport
avec mon déguisement
regardez en plein débat sur les
problèmes de la famille à l'idée les
chroniqueurs parlent aussi sérieusement
que si on traitait du thème du nucléaire
dans les balkans melain qui s'en fout
complètement du débat c'est le boss de
l'émission donc ces foulées aux pieds
l'âme de johnny de place à ces manques
mais excusez moi mais évidemment mais
avec aussi peut-être ce côté
exhibitionniste qui lui plaisait qui le
flatte et et moi je trouve que c'est
très bien
ll a envie de reposter des moments de sa
jeunesse l'honnêteté fleurs ballons des
magnifiques et regardez ces quatre
personnes en fait elles sont les
missions que plusieurs années donc voir
leur patron ont limité le dromadaire
assoiffés ça les perturbe pas une
seconde
en fait le seul qui est éberlué par vos
faces et c'est cyril c'est encore le
nouveau né avec naulleau
la semaine dernière vous avez voulu
perturber une nouvelle fois vos
chroniqueurs et ensemble vous avez bossé
de nouvelles idées masse c'est
magnifique c'est effectivement
représenter un pays censé représenter
toutes les femmes de son bailleur trouve
qu géorgien effectivement on réduit la
beauté à des critères qui sont
complètement dépassés effectivement donc
c'est complètement ridicule
les ringards qui veut supprimer c'est ça
qui est drôle comme c'est mardi gras
j'ai fait un petit truc je vous ai
transformé
regardez merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
kelly merci alors son anniversaire
aujourd'hui
vraiment oui vraiment
[Applaudissements]
attentat violent
adou que je fais chevalier des arts et
des chauffeurs livreurs et ben je
t'offre ça autre souvenir est d'accord
mais alors à ne pas mettre entre toutes
les mains
après donc fallu le faire un petit
cadeau
je veux bien sûr parler donc du
chauffeur livreur le plus le plus
célèbre du monde depuis quelques temps
si on vous dit toujours qu'il est
déprimé alors jean moulin j'ai voulu
vérifier parce que moi je les aime
beaucoup j'ai voulu vérifier si rarement
été déprimés j'ai pris une émission au
hasard jeudi dernier j'ai mis une caméra
isolé sur lui même quand il parlera il
ya des primés dont vous connaissez la
chanson destinée à l'air déprimé et
toujours déprimé
vous c'est correct moi j'essaie de faire
mon intéressant chez c'est de faire rire
j'ai c'est si je devais le faire c'est
ce que je fais en fait c'est rien ça
fonctionne pas du tout comme un témoin
dépression mais bon quand tu entends des
débats sur les végétariens [ __ ] des
primes des cochons qui ont été élevés
qu'en été heureux pendant leur vie de
cochon pendant l'été raymond sa collègue
pose une question à la con salle des
primes du flexitarisme vraiment et
toujours déprimé
vraiment les citations philosophiques
tirer d'nrj 12 salles des primo c'est de
l'or et tu crois que tu deviendras un
beau
[Musique]
et raymond même les vannes de cyril
hanouna auquel tout le monde rigole
bassam d'être émotions des prix mais
sans demander pour
cette race rhin
mais
non vraiment c'est ton anniversaire et
j'espère tu feras plein d'anniversaire
avec cbc la voilà c'est un ami sur une
dernière chose c'est nous les joueurs
yslandia voilà parce que quand michaël
youn quand il m'a dit c'est un peu le
bordel sur l'émission est en fait comme
d'habitude est très talentueux donc un
grand écart entre début d'émission en
fin d'émission
regardez j'adore
à 19 ans il a menacé de digne successeur
de patrick sébastien mais deux heures
après on avait l'impression devant le
digne héritier de jean luc delarue ou sk
nichols été discriminées ou sont si mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 19 ans il en avait le plus grand
animateur de sa génération en pleine
démonstration de dar k alors qu à 21h02
c'était aussi à l'honneur d'interviewer
sociétale si karl lagarfeld n'avait pas
fait de testament qui aurait empoché
médicale
[Applaudissements]
19h24 on a le droit ou cyril hanouna
danseurs contemporains
alors qu en fin d'émission nous arracher
presque les larmes il faut savoir qu'il
a renversé sa prime de show poudou c'est
lui direct à l'association premier de
cordée qui propose des initiatives
sportives pour les enfants hospitalisés
et bien cyril je sais que pour vous il
ya rien de mieux que dans tpm paix que
quand vous pouvez dire ce mot anglais ni
cook
[Applaudissements]
j
sarko merci à vous
[Applaudissements]